have you had any uh were you able to
communicate with doug or gunna at all
since everything that happened happened
obviously oh yeah through metro kind of
yeah so it sucks man because i feel like
uh
especially like using rap lyrics
is to me the craziest thing like obvious
art like we're talking about art that
charts on billboard i don't understand
how they're trying to say you know like
why cells are gang and they saying
certain things came from
the year like 2013 and ysl didn't come
about till he made the song stoner
so it's like everything they said is
[ __ ] and stoner came out in 2014
right exactly
so high saying this gang started then
they couldn't you know yeah no i think
it's the whole name came from stoner all
of it like literally like that's why i
was like okay
yeah and that's like a 100 million
dollar label
it's an llc it's a business that employs
people that's signed a major with 300
which is owned by a hundred million
dollar label yeah it's crazy yeah i just
don't really get it
what do you think like in terms of like
um
do you think artists should be more
careful about the [ __ ] that they rap
about of course
my big brother just told me the other
day heard finna shoot this fire as video
heard about this song coming out called
gossip
and he's shooting the video as far he
got it like we're a kid in the
interrogation room
and you know they come in and offer him
food offering cigarettes he won't tell
like he ain't saying nothing the police
come back in with a mic and a booth play
a beat like she feel what i'm saying
and he just can't help it he just
started rapping all the [ __ ] he done did
like you know but he's really trying to
tell kids like man i'll just
like stop going to rap [ __ ] that you
really doing if you're in the streets
like don't go do that cause they sit
down recording it
they use it they listening to it just to
use it against you like you know nah for
sure man a lot of these rappers got jobs
a lot of these rappers is not like what
the [ __ ] they're acting they saying
truthfully
i'm scary as [ __ ] yeah and like i feel
like um if you're
a if you get to a certain point of
success in your career as an artist like
i almost feel like you got to kind of
you got to kind of move like that you
know you got to kind of just start
moving like more of a
civilian i guess if that makes sense
just because of the current landscape of
[ __ ] casanova just
looking five to 25 years you know what i
mean obviously the six nine thing
happened like
so much crazy [ __ ] man
y'all know free cash no rest of my
brother i [ __ ] bro great guy
unfortunate like i really [ __ ] broke
free my brother
i know but i don't i don't speak on the
six-nine guy
yeah i mean i was just using him as an
example of a
rico thing happening yeah it's like
that's why it's like it's getting deep
to me you know yeah
it's getting super super deep um i think
about how many people these kids take
care of though like you know doug got
like 13 siblings
you know probably like i don't know a
lot of kids you got more kids than me
like take care of all his friends all
his siblings everybody like cousins
brothers like
yeah man and then obviously just sad to
me like you know what i'm saying just
like i know you take care of these
people like that's the most
generous person i know and then little
key passing away was rough my little
brother i love him see i got amg tatted
in my face my homie mexico mexico is one
of my best friends yeah you always talk
about long-lasting yeah he named he
named his album after mexico was my
friend like my real real friend
feel me really really my friend yeah
keith was one of the nicest kids that's
the first person to ever show me
ever ever in life that's crazy yeah yeah
yes rest in peace the kid man and mexico
both